this is season 20 a big brother BB 20
maybe 20 what does that mean to you
summer Steve summer Steve my name is
Steve Arrieta and I'm from Wanaque New
Jersey and why big brother why not
it's an awesome game it's a lot of fun
I'm a fan my wife's a fan kids are fans
and we're also is a 40 year old guy like
me gonna get the opportunity to win 500
grand so that's why I on the prize eye
on the prize would you categorize
yourself as like a casual viewer a
superfan someone who I know we're never
a superfan I'm a fan my wife is a
superfan okay but I do watch it I've
watched it for many years got my
favorite players so yeah I would say I'm
who's a Big Brother alum that you're
gonna steal some tactics right well I
think you'd be foolish not to steal
tactics from all people that you respect
so you know I definitely Dan he was a
coach real brute force but also a very
sneaky player Janelle rocked it my
competitions
you got beast mode with his athletic
ability I don't know if I can harness
any of that but I'll try Mike boogie I
mean he's just an awesome player it was
funny but also played a little vicious
at times when he had to knew how to play
the game play too well so yeah I mean
there's a whole lot you know you can
even take it some people that didn't
make it that far but take some things
off of them Donnie
yeah well light very sweet you know head
and stayed under the radar for a while
you know so there's little things you
got to take from each player to kind of
try to make it yours
you know the game you know these people
those are people from all over the place
yes sir all right this is season 20 a
big brother BB 20 maybe 20 what does
that mean to you summer Steve summers
Steve now uh it means it's an honor to
be here it's almost surreal if still
feel doesn't feel like I'm sitting here
speaking to you so
it's really a dream come true to be able
to try to win this money to support and
to further my family and I think that's
you know it's just I feel blessed I got
an awesome life an awesome wife I got
awesome marriage with awesome kids this
is just it just feels like icing on top
right now and I'm gonna make the most of
it so yeah you get a cool experience and
hopefully a big check at the end well
what better I mean that's that's a
summer right there and I get to sit in
the Sun in the pool and I'm competitive
so I get to compete I get to make
fifteen so-called friends no but in all
truthfulness I get to build bonds I get
to get to know other people I'm a very
social person so I think it melts well
with my personality with this being the
20th season expectation is high there
will be some crazy twists is there a
twist you would love to see you know
what given that a lot of thought I would
love to see possible veterans come back
I really would who would you want to
play with Mike buggy easy yes 100% I
would love to play with my boogie I
would like to play with Dan um you know
I I'd like to play with Paul and I know
he's been back a couple times but uh and
I think you know should have won the
last one sorry Paul but uh you know I
these are the people that pop in my head
you know if I wanted to play a nice nice
game I'd like to play with Donnie guy
that awesome even though everybody
thought he was a Navy SEAL I thought
that was hysterical
um but yeah now those are some of the
players off the top of my head that I
would love to play the game with is
there anyone you wouldn't want to play
with beetle dick okay though I respect
his game and I'm not gonna say anything
bad about and I don't know the person
personally but I can tell you this as a
father I can respect the fact that he
tried to take all the heat for his
daughter and I don't know you know I
wasn't there during production or
whatever the case may be but I can tell
you this I respected that play I just
wouldn't want to play well he's kind of
one of the most vicious players in Big
Brother history
how vicious do you plan on getting in
this house um I'm not a vicious person
at her say I'm not I you know I I guess
that's you know just me personally but I
can be cold and you're gonna have to get
cold if you want to win this game and
that's the truth listen I you know with
my background with the people I've
arrested in the past the people I've had
to put cases on you know I didn't think
they were bad people you know sometimes
some really good people do some really
bad things yeah
for whatever reason but you've got to
put your blinders on and do your job you
know right now this is me putting on my
boots about to go into the house to do
my job
and at the end hopefully there's a
paycheck for five hundred grand with my
name on your background are you gonna
keep that a secret from the house plus
seven hundred percent secret that ain't
coming out what's your cover story okay
um well you know I'd be given that a lot
of thought too and I love working on
cars I work on it in my nephew shop over
at Lodi New Jersey I'm gonna be a
mechanic family mechanic and a
family-owned garage okay no because
being a narcotics detective oh thanks
Derek
do you want it so that just became a
target University professor yeah okay
that's one too
so um you know I got to double threats
coming at me you use the father line but
that only goes so far because then
people don't want to know what you do
for a living yeah you know so the truth
is I know a lot about cars I know a lot
about motorcycles I love riding and I
actually like wrenching so I have no
problems waxing on and waxing off in
regards to automobile or anything
general mechanic wise got enough to sell
it all absolutely so it all day all
night long well it's safe to assume show
manses are not gonna be for you so it's
gonna be one less thing to think about
in that house yes sir
but are you gonna maybe try to inspire
some show mantis little off Oh see so
that's that's an excellent strategy
question you know the truth is um
you know she'll Nancy's bring a lot of
attention but they also bring a block
mode you know me and my past I've run
for politics I know all about block
voting the truth is if the person in my
alliance can is having a sort of a
showmance it does two different things
number one it brings another vote into
the Alliance number two though it can be
blind faith with that showmance him or
her or her and her him and him it
doesn't matter to me it's blind so I
might fan that flame of love at first
certain amount of time until it's time
to possibly cut bait okay good strategy
other than your background is there
anything else you don't want your fellow
houseguests to know um no I I gotta be
honest other than my occupational
background yeah well yeah I take that
back I don't want them to know I play
college football
I don't want them to know that I was an
all-state wrestler you know those are
the things that are obviously I hope
will come out during physical challenges
but I don't want them thinking oh my
gosh you know this guy's a possible
physical threat of 40 years old you know
I'm sure there's gonna be a lot younger
they're gonna be in great shape some
muscle guys muscle girls you know people
yoga instructors whatever the case might
be so the truth is I don't anticipate
winning a lot of physical competitions
but that is not my strength but I can
show myself to be competitive and I
don't want anybody to think that I'm
related to anybody famous because then
all of a sudden you become a target
again and I don't know who they could
think I would be related to but I don't
want that distinction either okay like
Donny was confused with being a Navy
SEAL no matter how many times he tried
to tell people he was a gardener he was
a Navy SEAL so ya know that that can't
happen alright this show also has a way
of bringing out secret from people's
pasts is there anything you want to
confess to now or that you're worried
about coming out anything like that no
like you got to have a pretty clean
background with what you did for a
living
ya know I know I didn't know I'm good
god I feel pretty good know I've been
married 17 and a half years three
beautiful daughters
oh no I'm retired in good standing for
the NYPD
I received tenure at the University I
teach at I love my students I love my
former coworkers everybody Manhattan
North narcotics keep your head up
oh my footing the to floor keep your
head up but no I feel pretty good
what do the wife and kids think about
dad going off and doing this very
supportive it's crazy you know it's one
of those things that doesn't happen
every day to a blue-collar hard-working
guy like it just doesn't but uh you know
they're very supportive my wife I trust
with my life so I you know I'm very
comfortable in knowing that she's okay
at home my kids the two leg the two are
older the two stepdaughters are older
and but I've been with tennis since they
were in their single digits you know I
they're great I mean I love my family
and I know that no matter what happens
in this game I'm going home to my family
so it's a real comforting a real warm
feeling of knowing you can get to go
home safe to say that they are what
you're going to miss most for this
potential three months I've been missing
them already I missed that I missed them
the minute I got on the plane so yeah is
there anything you're excited to give up
for three months like a person you're
happy to get away from no I you know the
guys I gotta be honest I I uh I live a
very blessed life all right
I love my friends they wouldn't be my
friends if I didn't want them around um
I love the people I talk to I you know
hey I can't think wait a minute yes I
can think I have a dog named buzz I'm
happy that I don't have to walk him in
the morning he's insane but yes either
than buzz I'm very happy with everybody
else so I'm just kidding I love it he's
just morning walks it's my wife's dog so
yeah he's glued to my wife but he's very
strong so I have to walk
and when he Kristen walks out when I'm
walking him he tries to charge towards
her and he's a handful okay but he's a
rescue we have three rescues nice why
are you gonna win big brother you know
give him that question a lot of thought
why am I gonna win break brother well
the truth is I think that I bring a lot
to the table I can be a physical threat
depending on the challenge I can be a
mental threat I'm having my academic and
my anthropological expertise in regards
to living life I I can be I can read
people
I very good at reading people so
interview an interrogation is something
I've done well in my detective career so
I hopefully can spot out lies the truth
is I think I bring a lot more to the
table than the other possible 15 other
houseguests we'll see how that all melds
out yeah but I'm gonna give it my best
shot and have some fun doing it
well good luck hopefully next time I see
you you've just won the game that'd be
fantastic absolute pleasure thank you
for having there we go
[Music]
[Applause]